classical rapido blitz which one do you
think is your strength the one you enjoy
the most
I'm more or less versatile in those
three formats challenging definitely is
the bullet and everything that has to do
with playing or coming up with extremely
fast reactions
I like rapid the most I I feel it's
combination of both classical needs so
it's not too slow
that it can last six hours a Gibson like
but it's also not too fast that the
moves are actually pretty good
of course over the cosmic career it's
been all of them at some point of the
other recently probably I would lean
slightly towards classical it goes back
and forth if you talk to me in 2018 or
2017 you would certainly have said rapid
and blitz was my strength
probably blitz more than rapid but in
2019 I've done terribly in grappling
blitz and well in Cusco previously ice
to consider myself good in all three but
then I then reality hit me and I became
more modest but to be honest I think
blitz and classical I feel atom my
strong suits I think it's for my style
and my strengths and weaknesses the
rapids should be my strongest point but
as I'm focusing on the classical mostly
and my preparation routine is suited
best for the classical chest definitely
blitz I think is probably my bass
although I've had great results in rapid
let's talk about your competitors what
do you think is best trend
well Magnus is strength definitely
strongest in in classical he's of course
very universal plays plays well in all
three but definitely classical is his
biggest strength
I think blitz probably he immediately
sees where a piece should go and yeah
and it's
you know that's an advantage link is
very good in classical I think I believe
if strongest in blitz he plays fast like
he just plays like automatically at the
moment I would say he's very good in
classical oh that's not even a question
definitely class go ding is just very
very strong his strength everything
basically car is very good in blitz
because he has a huge experience blitz
again I would say that he still got very
very strong instincts for wrapping a
blitz what he needs to do is probably to
follow them a bit more it carries the
bit King right Wesley Wesley Wesley um
probably the best in rapid his his good
and bliss as well but he is more
confident when he has a little bit more
time sometimes he plays really well in
Rabbid sometimes well blitz he's just
all over the place I think he's probably
about the same strength in all three a
level on this an extremely strong
practical player and his biggest
strength and his biggest weakness is his
relentless optimism it's not bits maybe
classical this XI I think I mean in the
earlier certainly was a very strong
rapid player he's well known for that in
more recent years I think probably his
strength I mean if you were asked me
probably say prefers classical Vichy is
best in blitz and because he plays very
fast he always has a lot of time oh
that's a tough question because he's so
balance in everything I would say that
his consistency recently has been very
impressive in the Grantchester he never
plays very badly so yeah that's been in
being impressive
you